Hello and welcome to MetaHuman Fitting and DNA Calibration.
My name is Gabriela Crusenio-Tacis and I will be your host for this course.
In this course, we will be going over recommended workflows that can be used to modify and customize
the neutral pose of the MetaHuman face using the MetaHuman Framework Toolset.
Due to the number of workflows that are involved on this topic,
this class has been split up into two courses.
The next course, MetaHuman DNA Calibration and Finalization,
will be the continuation of this course where we explore more advanced use cases using DNA calibration
and go over how we can bring the modified assets back into Unreal Engine.
It is worth noting that the DNA calibration workflows we will be covering in both courses
have changed in later Engine versions and we will be exploring those changes in a future update.
In this course, we begin by exploring the complexity of the MetaHuman face and MetaHuman Framework Tools
such as the DNA calibration repository that can be used for making adjustments to the neutral pose.
We then touch upon expectations as to how far customizations can be pushed before encountering issues.
Next, we will cover common workflows for fitting MetaHuman topology to scan our sculpted meshes.
From there, we move on to two hands-on exercises.
In the first one, we will export a MetaHuman identity conformed mesh from Unreal Engine to be used for additional fitting.
And for the second one, we will use the mesh to MetaHuman workflow with the template mesh option
to generate a MetaHuman identity that will be solved based on geometry.
From there, we will delve into best practices for fitting the additional head geometry assets.
Then we move on to the DNA calibration section of this course.
We will cover setting up the DNA calibration repository
and we'll get acquainted with the files and scripts that we will be using.
We will use the example script from the repository to modify the neutral pose inside of Autodesk Maya.
We will make some minor adjustments directly on the head mesh and with the joints and skin clusters.
Then we will update the MetaHuman DNA and export the head LODs as FBX.
Finally, we will wrap up this course with some final recommendations
and I will share some tips and resources for you to use
as you continue your work and training with MetaHumans.
This course will be using the project MEH9130055 and there are two level maps.
Both maps are located in the content browser under the courses folder labeled MEH21302
in the course maps folder. The first map is named MEH21302MAPS
which should load automatically. S stands for Standard MetaHuman.
In this map we have two versions of the preset LENA.
We have the original version and the version that has been modified
using the 2023 UnrealFest DNA calibration script.
The second map is named MEH21302MAPC for Custom.
I will double click on this to open it.
This map has a stylized MetaHuman named Atomic Savage
that has been customized using more advanced DNA calibration scripts.
The assets that we will be using in this project are located in the course assets folder.
The folder named ATOMICSAnom contains a body animation that has been retargeted to this character.
The folder named CONFORMEDMASH contains the fitted conformed mesh that we will use for
one of the hands-on exercises. The folder named SEQUENCES contains two level sequences you can
play that include a body and face animation. The ATOMICS sequence can be used in the map
with ATOMICSavage and the sequence labeled LENADNA can be used in the map with the modified version
of LENA. The source files folder named 21302 FITTADNA assets will contain the assets that
have been used for the modified MetaHumans in both maps if you wish to inspect them.
If at any point you need to reference the location of the course maps,
they can be found at the beginning of the slide deck after the training outline.
As we go through this course you will find that many slides in this presentation
contain a lot of information and I will summarize all of that. But if at any point you want to read
what is on each of those slides, feel free to pause and dive right in. Now let's begin with the first
portion of this course by exploring the complexity of the MetaHuman face, DNA calibration, and expectations
for achieving likeness.